The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
CHARLES LEISERSON: So today
we're going to take a little
bit closer look at what's
happening under the covers
when you compile a C program.
But before we get into that,
we did a little interesting
correlation on your scores for
the first problem, for the
every bit one.
So this is basically plotting.
It's a scatter plot of how you
did in your test coverage
score versus how you did in
your correctness score and
performance, correctness and
performance together.
And what's interesting is that
if you did better in your test
coverage, you did better
in your performance and
correctness.
OK, that's a pretty good
correlation, right?
There's some outliers here.
But that's a pretty
good correlation.
Yeah, John?
Yeah?
JOHN: The--
CHARLES LEISERSON: Do
we have a handheld?
Here we go.
Just a second.
The only thing is we have to
figure out how to turn it on.
There we go.
JOHN: Yeah, so just to clarify,
the people who
seemingly got no test coverage
but really good performance
scores, what actually happened
was that we tested for things
that we didn't expect students
to cover for like on feeding
invalid values to better a set
and better a get or testing
for private functions to
their implementations.
So in reality they had better
test suites than the coverage
score would indicate.
CHARLES LEISERSON: So what
are the lessons that
one draws from this?
So professional engineers know
what the lessons are.
So the lessons are that it is
actually better, if you have a
coding problem to do, to
write tests first.
Before you code you
write your tests.
And that actually speeds
the development of
fast correct code.
It's actually faster.
You get to the end result
much faster.
Because whenever you make an
error in your program, you
instantly know that you may
have a problem rather than
thinking that you're doing
something OK and then
discovering that, oh, in fact
your code is, in fact,
incorrect, and you're working
away optimizing something
that's not working So before
coding, it's highly
recommended that
you write test.
Also if you find a bug, when
you find a bug, the first
thing you should do is write a
test for that bug if it wasn't
already covered.
Then you fix the bug.
And then you make sure that your
test now, that your new
implementation, passes
that particular one.
Professional engineers
know this.
Professional software developers
It comes hard.
And if you want a job at any
top flight software firm,
they're going to expect that you
know that you write tests
first before you do coding.
The second lesson isn't quite
so obvious from this.
But it's the second lesson
that I think some people
experienced in the class which
was the idea of putting you in
groups, in particular in pairs,
was not so that you
could do divide and conquer
on the code.
It was to do pair programming.
And what we found was that
a bunch of groups
divided up the work.
And they said, OK, it'll go
faster if you do this one and
I do that one.
Once again that's probably
a mistake.
If you can sit together and
take turns at the keyboard
making the changes, it may seem
like it's going slower to
begin with, but it's amazing how
many errors you catch and
how quickly you find your errors
because you're just
talking with each other.
And it's like, oh, duh.
So good programmers know this.
That it really helps to have
more than one person
understand what's going
on in the code.
So the people who had difficulty
with their partners
one way or another often did
not, it was partly because
they just divided up the work,
you're responsible for that,
oh, we got a bad grade on
that, that's your fault.
No, both partners own
that grade 100%.
And the best way to ensure
is to work together.
Now, this sometimes flies in the
face of people who believe
that they are clever or more
experienced than somebody,
than their partner, oh, I can do
this much better on my own.
Usually, that's true for little
projects, but as the
projects get bigger that
becomes a much harder
situation to deal with.
It becomes the case that you
really want two brains looking
at the same thing, four
eyes as opposed to two
eyes looking at things.
But I think, in particular,
before coding write test.
And we are right now working
on improving the
infrastructure.
One of the things that they have
in most companies is, at
the very minimum, they have
what's called a nightly build.
Nightly build says they take all
the software, they build
it, and then they run regression
tests against it
all night while everybody's
home sleeping.
Come in the next morning, here's
the things that broke.
And if you broke the
build, you got some
work to do that morning.
And it's generally not a good
idea to break the build.
What has been demonstrating,
in fact, is that continuous
build is even better.
This is where, whenever you make
a change to the program,
you run the full suite
of tests on it.
And we're going to
look into it.
We have to see what
our resources are.
As you know, our TAs are
a limited resource.
But we're going to look into
seeing whether we can provide
more of that kind of
infrastructure on some of the
later projects for you folks.
So you can sort of see
the matrix that we
eventually got to you.
You can see that develop
in real time.
How am I doing against
other people's tests?
How are they doing against
my tests, et cetera?
So we'll see whether
we can do that.
But what's funny is you think
that it'd be faster to just
code and do it.
Computer science is full
of wonderful paradoxes.
And one of them is that doing
things like writing the extra
code to test is actually faster
than not writing it,
surprisingly.
It really gets you to the
end result a lot faster.
Any questions about that?
Any comments about that?
Let's talk about our today.
So today we're going to talk
mostly about single threaded
performance.
This is one instruction
stream that you're
trying to make go fast.
But if you look at today's
computing milieu, how all of
the computers are used,
what do you have?
You've got networks of
multi-core clusters.
It's parallelism everywhere.
You've got shared memory among
processors within a chip.
You've got message passing among
machines in a cluster.
You've got network protocols
among clusters so that you can
do wide area things.
Yet we're saying, no, let's take
a look at what happens on
one core on one machine.
So why is that important
to focus first on what
one core can do?
Why study single threaded
performance at all?
Let's just go do the
parallel stuff.
That's more fun anyway.
Well, there are a couple of
reasons that I can think of.
The first one is at the end of
the day, even if you've got
something running widely in
parallel, the code is running
in each core in a single
threaded manner.
You just have a bunch of them.
And so if you've given up a
factor of two or a factor of
four in performance or even
more, as you're aware, you can
sometimes make it orders of
magnitude, but in performance
what you're saying is that
you're going to end up using
much more resources to do your
particular job in parallel.
And resources is money.
So if I can do the job with a
cluster of 16 processors and
somebody else can do it in
a cluster with only four
processors, hey, they just spent
a quarter the amount on
not just the capital investment
in that hardware
but also the operating costs
of what it cost to actually
cool and provide electricity to
and maintain and so forth.
All that gets much cheaper.
So if you get good single
thread performance, it
translates.
That's kind of the
direct reason.
The indirect reason is, for
studying it, is that many of
the lessons will generalize.
So things that we'll see for
single core, there is an
analogy when you start
looking at parallel
and distributed systems.
So that's a little
less concrete.
But as you'll see as you gain
experience, you'll see that
there's a lot of lessons that
generalize to how do you think
about performance no matter
what the context.
So what about a single
threaded machine?
What's it like?
So some of this is going to be a
little bit review, but we're
going to just sort
of go deeper.
We've sort of been taking
layers off the onion.
And today we're going
to take a few more
layers off the onion.
So you have inside
a processor core.
You've got registers.
You've got the functional
units to do your ALU
operations, floating point
units, vector units these
days, and all the stuff to do
instruction, execution, and
coordination, scheduling,
out of order
execution, and so forth.
In addition then, you have
a memory hierarchy.
Within the core, you typically
have registers
and L1 and L2 caches.
And then outside the core
often is the L3 cache.
DRAM memory, you may have
a solid-state drive
these days and disk.
And so in that context,
you're trying to make
your code run fast.
So when you compile the piece
of code, so here I have a
piece of code.
I'm always amused when I put up
a Fibonacci as the example.
Because this is a really
terrible way to compute
Fibonacci numbers.
So this is an exponential time
algorithm for computing
Fibonacci numbers.
And you may be aware you can do
this in linear time just by
adding up from the bottom.
In fact, if you take the
algorithms course, you learn
that you can actually do this in
logarithmic time by matrix,
recursive squaring
of matrices.
So it's sort of interesting to
put up something where we say
we're going to optimize this.
And, of course, we'll get a
constant factor improvement on
something like this.
But, in fact, really this is a
terrible program to write for
optimization.
But it's good didactically.
And Fibonacci numbers
are fun anyway.
So typically what happens is
when you run GCC on your .C
file and produce a binary, what
happens is it produces
the machine code, which is
basically a string of bytes,
zeros and ones.
And that goes, when you run the
program, that goes through
the hardware interpreter.
So the hardware of the machine
is doing an interpretation of
these very simple instructions
and produces an execution.
But, in fact, there's actually
four stages that go on inside
of GCC if you type a
command like this.
The first thing is what's
called preprocessing.
And what that does is it does
any macro expansion and so
forth, things that are just
basically on the level of
textual substitutions
before you get into
the guts of the compiler.
Then you actually
do the compiler.
And that produces a version of
machine code called assembly
language, which we'll see
in just a minute.
And from that version of
assembly language it then goes
into a process called linking
and loading, which actually
causes it to produce
the binary that
you can then execute.
So all four stages are
included here.
And there are switches to GCC
that let you do only one or
all of these things.
You can, for example, run
the preprocessor GCC.
You can tell it to run the
preprocessor alone and see
what all your macros
expanded to.
Yes?
Question?
AUDIENCE: What's the difference
between compiling
and assembling?
CHARLES LEISERSON: So compiling
reduces it to
essentially assembly language.
And then assembling is taking
that assembly language and
producing the machine binary.
AUDIENCE: I was going to say,
there's a one-to-one
correspondence between machine
code and assembly, but there's
not a one-to-one correspondence
between C code
and assembly.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah.
So there's actually not
quite a one to one,
but it's very close.
It's very close.
So you can think of it as one
to one between assembly
machine code.
But assembly is, in some sense,
a more human readable
and understandable version
of machine code.
In fact, that's what we're
going to talk about.
So let's go directly
to assembly code.
To do that I can use
the minus S switch.
Now it turns out it's
also helpful to
use the minus G switch.
Minus G says give me all the
debugger symbol tables.
And what that makes it is so
that you can actually read the
assembly language.
If you don't have that
information, then you don't
know what the programmer
wrote as the symbols.
Instead you will get
computer generated
symbol names for things.
And you don't have any
meaning to those.
So it's really a good
idea to use minus
G and minus S together.
And this basically provides
a convenient symbolic
representation of the
machine language.
And this is sort of the type
of thing that you'll get,
something coming out that
looks like this.
It's basically an Ascii.
It's in text, characters,
rather than being in the
binary executable.
And if you want, you can find
out all the vagaries of it.
This is one site that has some
reasonable documentation on
the GNU assembler.
It's actually not as good on
the instructions, but it's
really good on all the
directives, which we'll talk
about in a minute like .global
and .type and all that stuff.
It's very good on that stuff.
There's another thing
that you can do.
And once again, it's also
helpful if you've produced a
binary that has the
symbol table.
And that is to do a dump
of the object code.
And when you do a dump of the
object code, what it does is
you basically give it an
executable and it goes
backwards the other way, take
this executable and undo one
step, disassemble it.
And what's good about object
dump is that it gives you,
first of all, these are all
the byte codes of the
instructions.
Also if you've got the minus S
says interleave the source
code, so you can see, here's the
source code interleaved.
So you can see which
regions of code
depend on which things.
And so it basically tells you
where in memory it's being
loaded, it's been loaded, what
the instructions are.
And then it gives you the
assembly interpretation of
that machine binary.
And this is where you can see
it's almost one to one what's
going on here.
Here we have a push
of an operand.
And that notice is just
a one byte code.
Whereas here we've got an opcode
and two arguments.
And it has three bytes
as it turns out.
So you can see there's sort
of a correspondence.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: How does
[? logic then take the ?]
machine language code
and go to--
how does it know the function
names and stuff?
CHARLES LEISERSON: It knows
the function names because
when you compile it with -g,
it produces, in addition to
producing the binary, it
produces a separate segment
that's not loaded in that has
all that information that
says, oh, at this location
is where this symbol is.
And it produces all that as
stuff that's never loaded in
at run time but which
is there in order to
aid debuggers mainly.
Question?
AUDIENCE: To compile something
not using the gflag and then
you do an object dump,
how would that work?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Then what
happens is, first of all, you
would not be able to get
this stuff interleaved.
And then things like here where
it says fib, well, fib
may be an external name so
you might know it anyway.
But if it were an internal name,
you would not be able to
see what it was.
Yeah, if you're going
to respond let's
get you on mike here.
Why don't you just hold this?
JOHN: Yeah, so you'll generally
get the function
names so you know roughly
a huge blob of assembly
corresponds to a function.
But you won't be able to get
any information about what
variables are in which registers
or what position the
sixth line of assembly
corresponds to in terms of
your source code.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Then the
other thing that you can do is
you can actually take the
assembler, the assembly code,
if you produce just the assembly
code, and if you tell
GCC to take a .s file, which is
the assembly code, you can
produce the machine
code from it.
And so one thing that you can
do is you can produce a .s
file and then edit it in Emacs
or VI or whatever your
favorite text editor is and
then assemble it with GCC.
So you can actually
modify what the
machine code is directly.
And that's what we're going to
spend a little bit of time
doing today.
Let's go in and see what the
compiler generates and then
let's twiddle it a bit.
So here's what we're going to
expect that you do, that
you're able to do.
We expect in this class that
you're going to be able to
understand how a compiler
implements the C linguistic
constructs using x86
instructions.
We're going to expect that you
can read x86 assembly language
with the aid of a manual.
We don't expect that you know
all the instructions, but the
basic ones we expect that
you know what those are.
We expect that you're going
to be able to make simple
modifications to the assembly
language generated by a
compiler, and that you would
know, if push came to shove,
how to write your own machine
code on your own.
That's not something we're going
to expect that you do,
but you would know how to get
started to do that if at some
point you said, oh,
I really have to
write this in assembler.
So this is, as I say, really
we're going to take off some
layers of the onion today, try
to get down what's going on.
It turns out this is actually
kind of fun.
Now, the part that's not fun
at some level is the x86 64
machine model.
The x86 is what's
called a complex
instruction set computer.
And these, long ago, were
demonstrated to be inferior to
so-called reduced instruction
set computers.
But that hasn't mattered
in the marketplace.
What's mattered in the
marketplace is who could build
better and faster chips.
And also the amount of people
who started using the x86
instruction set has produced
a huge legacy and inertia.
It's sort of like some people
might argue that Esperanto is
a better language for everybody
to learn than English.
But how come English with all
its complexities and so forth,
and I'm sure for some of you who
have learned English as a
second language, it's like
it's a crazy language.
Who do you learn English?
Well, it's because that's what
everybody's learning.
That's where the legacy is.
And so x86 is very much
like the English of
machines these days.
So in this model there's
basically a flat 64-bit
address space.
There are 16 64-bit general
purpose registers, and then
what are some segment registers,
a register full of
flags, an instruction pointer
register, rest in peace.
They're eight 80-bit floating
point data registers, some
control status registers, an
opcode register, a floating
point instruction pointer
register, and a floating point
data pointing register, some
MMX registers for the
multimedia extensions, and a
128-bit XMM registers for the
SSE instructions, which are the
ability to have an opcode
run over several pieces of data
at once, short vectors,
vector instructions, and a
32-bit register that frankly I
don't have a clue as
to what it does.
So, fortunately, we don't
have to know all these.
You can look at the architecture
manual if any of
these become important.
So our goal is not to memorize
the x86 instruction set.
That would be a punishment
probably worse than death.
The only thing worse would
be learning all of C++.
So here's the general
registers.
So there are basically
64-bit registers.
And here's the mnemonics
that they have.
So you can see is all very
mnemonic, right?
We got some of them
that are numbered.
How come they're all
just not numbered?
I mean come on, right?
I know why.
Don't tell me.
So what you get to do is look at
and remember that there are
all these fun registers.
And what they did is the x86
64 architecture grew out of
the x86 which was 32-bit.
Well, in fact, originally
it was 16-bit.
And it's been extended twice
to have more bits in the
instruction word so
that now it's a
64-bit instruction word.
And what they did in order to
make it so that they could run
legacy code more easily, which
might have been written with a
smaller word size, is they've
overlap so that the EAX
register, for example,
is the low order
32-bits of the RAX register.
So what you do is you'll see
that R is the prefix that
says, hey, that's a
64-bit register.
E is the prefix that
says that it is--
Whoops, I made a
mistake there.
Those should all be Es.
Oh, no, sorry, no, there's
are correct.
These are R and then with
D because these are the
extended ones, yes.
So these are D. So R and D, that
means also that it's 16.
So you can see just how easy
this is to remember without a
cheat sheet, right?
And then you go down
to 15, et cetera.
And so you can go all the way
down to byte naming, the low
order byte of the registers.
In addition, it turns out
that that's not all.
But the high order byte of the
16-bit registers are also
available as independently
named registers.
When you're using this in a C
program, there's a convention
that C has.
And it's actually different
on Windows from on Linux.
Because there's no reason they
should make those things
compatible.
That would be too easy.
So instead they have
different ones.
But the ones on Linux, this is
essentially the structure.
What happens when you call a
subroutine is generally you're
passing the arguments to the
subroutine in registers.
And in fact the first
six arguments are
passed in these registers.
RDI, you'll get very
familiar with RDI.
Because that's where the first
argument is always passed.
And almost all your functions
will have a first argument,
except for the ones that have
no arguments, and then the
second arguments, the third,
and so forth, and
then fifth and sixth.
If you get more than six, then
it turns out, then you start
passing arguments
through memory.
But otherwise the convention
is that the arguments are
passed through registers.
There are a couple of other
important registers.
One here is the return value
always comes back in RAX.
So when a function returns,
boom, that's where, RAX is
where the value of
the return is.
There is a base pointer and a
stack pointer which give you
the stack frame so that when you
do a push and want to push
local variables those are
telling you the limits of your
local variats.
And we'll talk more about
that a little bit.
And then there are a variety
of other ones.
Some are callee saved and
some are caller saved.
And you can refer
to this chart.
And there are others similar to
it in the various manuals.
Now, it gets pretty confusing,
if this isn't confusing enough
for the naming.
Let's go on to how you
name data types.
And I think some of you have
already experienced this a
little bit, the beauties
of the data types.
So in C, they have all these
different data types such as
I'm listing here.
And if you want to generate a
constant of that size, so
sometimes the compiler will
coerce a value from one type
to another.
But sometimes it won't.
And so if you want to have a
constant, and I've just given
a couple things here, for
example, if you want it to be
just an int, you can just
write the number.
But if you want it to be
unsigned, you have to
put a U after it.
Or if you want it to be
a long, you have to
put an L after it.
And for many things it'll get
coerced automatically to the
right type because if you do
an operator with another
argument it will be coerced
to that type.
But some of you got burned on
some of the shift things to
begin with because it wasn't
clear what exactly the sizes.
Well, you can be explicit in
C and name them using this
particular convention.
This tells you how many bytes
are being allocated for that
type in the x86 64 size.
So it's [? veted ?]
here for four.
Now, long double
is a funny one.
It's actually allocate
16 bytes, but only
10 of them are used.
So basically there are six bytes
that get unused by that.
And I think that's for future
expansion so that they can
have even wider extension.
This is generally used, of
course, for floating
point and so forth.
Now, in the assembly language,
each of the
operators has a suffix.
And sometimes, if it's a two
operand instruction, it may,
where it's taking things of
different sizes, it may have
two suffixes.
But it has a suffix which is a
single character that tells
you what the size is that
you're working with.
So, for example,
B is for byte.
W is for word because
originally the
words were 16 bits.
L is for long except that
it's not a long
so don't get confused.
L is not long.
Long is a quad word,
or Q, four bytes.
And then a float is an S. A
double is a D. And a long
double is a T.
So these you will get
familiar with.
And they're not so hard.
But that doesn't mean you know
them right off the bat.
And it helps to have
a cheat sheet.
As I say, the main one not to
get confused about is the Ls.
L means something different
in x86 than it means in C.
So, for example, here we have a
move of, and because it's a
Q, I know that it is an eight
byte or a 64-bit operator.
And you can tell that also
because it's using RBP and
RAX, both of which are
64-bit registers.
In fact, in assembly, you can
actually write it without the
Q, because the assembler can
infer when the Q isn't there
that, oh, this is a 64-bit
register, that's a 64-bit
register, I bet he means
move 64-bits.
So it actually fills
that in sometimes.
But sometimes you need
to be explicit.
Question?
AUDIENCE: What happens when
you actually put 64-bit
registers but you only, and
you just put move [? b ?]
or something?
Would it complain?
Would it [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah,
it would complain.
Yeah, it would complain.
it'll say it's an improperly
formed instruction, so, yeah.
And the other thing you
can do, of course,
is just try it out.
What happens if?
That's the great thing
about computers.
It's easy to do what
happened if.
Now, the instruction format is
typically an opcode followed
by an operand list.
So the opcode is a short
mnemonic identifying the type
of instruction that includes
typically the single character
suffix indicating
the data type.
However, for some instructions
it turns out you can have two
suffixes if the two--
Most instructions operate on
data types of the same size.
But some of them operate on two
different sizes in which
case you'll have two suffixes.
If the suffix is missing, it can
generally be inferred, as
I mentioned.
Then the operand list is from
zero, two, and very rarely
three operands separated
by commas.
Now, in the architecture manual,
in fact, they say if
you look at it, they'll show
you fourth operand.
And I said, four operands?
This documentation says
there's only three.
This one says there's four.
I went through the whole
architecture manual last night.
Every time it says four
operands, it says N/A, not
applicable.
So I think it's just there
reserved or something.
But anyway there is no fourth
operand as far as I can tell.
Now, one of the operands
is the destination.
And here's where we start to
get into some differences.
There's actually two standard
formats for assembly language
that are generally called Intel
and AT&T. So AT&T was
the original Unix system.
And Intel is what Intel uses
for their assembler.
They do the destination operand
in the opposite order.
So AT&T, it puts the
destination last.
In Intel it puts the
destination first.
So when you're reading
documentation, you can read
the Intel documentation.
You just have to remember to
flip it around if you're
actually writing it as we will
be using the AT&T format.
Almost everybody uses
AT&T as far as I
can tell except Intel.
So Intel's assembler does
it the other way around.
And actually now GCC will
actually, you can give it a
directive to say I'm now
switching to writing it in
Intel assembler.
So you can actually go back and
forth between the two if
you happen to borrow some
assembly language code from
somebody else.
So one of them is
the destination.
The other operations are
read-only, so const in the C++
terminology.
They're read-only.
So it's always the case that
only one of them is going to
be modified.
And that's the one that's the
destination of the operation.
In addition in assembler, there
are what are called
directives.
Besides the instructions,
there are directives.
So first of all there are
things like labels.
You can take any instruction
and put an identifier and a
colon, and that becomes then
a way of naming that
place in your code.
So, for example, jump
instructions want to know to
where they're jumping.
And rather than having to know
upfront what the address is,
the assembler will calculate
what that address is and
everywhere you put x, it'll
put in the right value.
And you get to name it
symbolically rather than as an
absolute machine location.
There are storage directives.
So, for example, .space 20
says allocate 20 bytes at
location x.
.long says store the
constant 172 at y.
It's being stored at y because
I said y is here.
And asciz gives you a string
that's zero terminated.
So the standard for strings
is zero terminated.
You can also, there's one
that says give me a
nonterminated string.
So you can have fun with
that if you like that.
The align directive says make
sure that as you're going
through, so what's happening
is the assembler is going
through there, is it's laying
these things out in memory
typically sequentially, the way
you wrote it down in the
program, in the assembly
language program.
If you say align eight, it
says advance whatever the
pointer is of where the next
thing is going to be put to be
a multiple of eight.
And that way you don't run the
risk of where you declare a
character and then you say, OK,
and now I want a long or
something, and it's not aligned
in a way that the
eight bytes correspond to a
multiple of eight the way you
need to in order for
the instructions to
properly work on them.
So generally, although, we
have byte pointers, most
instructions only work
on aligned values.
And for some of them that work
on unaligned values, they're
generally slower than the ones
that work on aligned values.
There are also segment
directives.
So in memory when you run your
program, the executing program
starts with the program text
down at the bottom of memory.
And then it has fixed data
that's not going to change,
static allocation of data.
And then it's got heap, which is
dynamically allocated data.
And then it's got stack.
The stack grows downward, and
the heap grows upward.
By saying something like text,
it says make sure that the
next stuff I'm putting goes
into the text segment.
So that's generally where
you put your code.
Saying it's in data says make
sure it goes in here.
So you may want to have
a table, for example.
So, for example, from pentominos
you might have a
table there.
There's going to be
a fixed table.
You're never going to
change it during the
running of the program.
Put it in the data segment.
And then there's also things
like scope and linkage
directives.
So saying .global, and you can
either spell it incorrectly,
as I have here, or with the a,
it's the same thing for the
GNU assembler anyway.
It says make the symbol fib
externally visible.
And that makes sure that it goes
into the symbol table so
that debuggers and things
can look at it.
And there's a lot more of these
in the assembler manual,
that link that I showed you to
before, tells you what all the
directives mean.
So that when you're looking at
code, which mostly you'll be
reading it, making a few changes
to it, you can know
what things mean.
So the opcode examples,
here's some examples.
There are things like
mov, push, and pop.
So, for example, here movslq,
this is an interesting one
because it's moving.
The s says extend the sign
because I'm moving from a long
from a 32-bit word to a 64-bit
word, from 4-bits to 8-bits.
So that's why this one takes
two suffixes moving from,
you'll notice, a 32-bit register
to a 64-bit register.
So you have to be careful.
This is something I got caught
up in the other day.
The results of 32-bit operations
are implicitly
extended to 64-bit values.
So if you store something into
EAX, for example, it
automatically zeroes out the
high order 32-bits of RAX.
Because that's the one that
it's embedded in.
However, that's not true for
the eight and 16-bit
operations.
If you store into an 8-bit
field, an 8-bit part of the
register, it does not
zero out the high
order bits of the remainder.
So you just have to be careful
when you're doing that.
Most of these are things, by the
way, that is more cryptic
when you're looking at stuff.
It's like, oh, how come it's,
gee, I thought I had, I'm
returning a double word, but
it looks here like it's
returning a 32-bit word,
how come I thought I
was returning 64--
Well, the answer is because
it knows the high
order bits are zero.
So it's using the shorter
instructions.
And yet it still is having the
impact on the 64-bit register.
They're all the arithmetic
and logical operations.
So subtracting, once again,
the destination is second.
So typically these are
two operator things.
So you always have the
destination occurs both at the
beginning and on the left hand
side and the right hand side,
things like shifts and rotates,
control transfer, so
call which does a subroutine
jump, return from a
subroutine, a jump instruction
that just says make the next
instruction the thing that
you're pointing to, and very
important, the jump conditionals
where the
condition is a whole bunch of
keys that are things like
greater than, less than, and so
forth, and different ones
for signed and unsigned
and so forth.
So typically the condition is
computed by using a compare
instruction.
I probably should have put CNP
on here as well, but I didn't.
But the CNP instruction is
usually what you use to
compare two things and then you
separately jump on what
the condition is.
There's a pretty nice
website that has
most of these opcodes.
However, they only deal
with the old x86
without the 64-bit extension.
And they use the Intel syntax.
But it's really convenient.
Because they've done a nice
job of making a quick jump
table where you can just
go, look up the
opcode, and pop it up.
Otherwise you can just look
at them in the manual.
Anyway, that's kind of
a convenient place.
And, as I say, just beware
because it's 32-bit only, and
it's Intel syntax.
Most of the instructions
got extended.
I mean it's like, OK, if you do
it for eight and 16 and 32,
the operation is not going to
change that much to go to 64.
A few of them do, however.
Now, the operands, Intel
supports, the x86, which is
Intel and AMD, typically,
support all kinds of
addressing modes.
The rule is that only
one operand,
however, can address memory.
So you have to pick which is
the operand that's going to
address memory if you have
multiple operands.
You can't have both operands.
So you can't add two
things in memory.
You always have to take
something for memory and bring
it into a register and then
store it back out.
So the simplest one is two
register instructions.
Here I've basically
marked the--
What have I marked here?
I guess I marked--
I don't know.
Down here I was marking
memory.
I'm not sure what I was
marking up here.
Because they're both
registers.
But in any case, this is just
adding RBX into RAX.
And so it takes the contents
of RBX adds it in
the contents of RAX.
There's something that's
called direct.
So this is, it says, where you
move, x is some constant
value, and you move it, the
contents of it, into RDI.
So if x, for example, is a
location that you've stored a
value in, you can say move
whatever is the value at that
location into RDI.
Immediate says, which usually is
preceded by a dollar sign,
says move the address of it,
move that as a constant.
So x has a value,
move that value.
So if you say $3, then
you'll move the
constant three into RDI.
If you said mov3 this, you're
going to move the contents of
location three in memory.
So that's the difference between
direct and immediate.
So the dollar sign says
you're taking that
as a literal constant.
And the direct says you're
actually going to memory and
fetching it.
Then things start getting
interesting.
Register indirect says, in
this case, the thing that
you're going to access
is the thing
pointed to by that register.
So don't move, in this case, RBX
into RAX, move it to the
memory location that
RAX is pointing to.
Then you can do register index
which says, well, it's
pointing to it, but I want
displaced 172-bytes off of
that location, of whatever
this is pointing to.
So, for example, if you have a
pointer to a record, you can
then have just a single pointer
and address all the
fields just by doing register
indirect to the different
fields using that
same register.
Then there is, it actually--
I skipped, actually, a few in
here that are subsets of this.
This is, I think, the most
complicated one that I know.
It's base index scale
displacement where base and
index are registers, the scale
is two, four, eight, and if
it's not there, it
implies one.
The displacement is eight,
16, or a 32-bit value.
And it says take RD--
oh, I had put the math on here,
and then I guess I lost
it-- it says take RDX, multiply
it by eight, add RDI,
and add 172.
[WHISTLE].
So, anyway, you can look
in the manual.
So you'll see some of these
instructions being generated.
Generally, you're not going to
generate these instructions.
So when you see them generated,
you can see it.
And then, and this is actually
new, it's not in the x86.
It has this instruction pointer
where you can actually
access where the current program
counter is pointing,
where it is in the code, and
store that value, in this case
indexed by six, into RAX.
So you can do it relative
where this has
to be a 32-bit constant.
And what's good about that is
it allows you then to write
code where you can do things
like jump to something that's
relative to the program
counter.
And that lets you put the code
anywhere in memory, and it
still has the same behavior.
Because you're going relative
to where that code is rather
than to an absolute location.
So it allows the code
to be relocatable.
So here's--
Yeah, questions, yeah sure.
AUDIENCE: Why was it the index
registers, when you have the
numbering for the register,
what does that mean again?
CHARLES LEISERSON: The number
before the register?
AUDIENCE: In the instruction
[UNINTELLIGIBLE],
that's 60 for RID.
CHARLES LEISERSON: OK, or
whatever, whenever it's here,
it's basically saying,
add that value to
the contents of RAX.
And so the same thing here, add
six to the contents of the
instruction.
So this is six bytes ahead of me
in the instruction stream.
OK?
So you can actually say, well,
what's that instruction ahead
of me in the instructions
stream?
OK?
So here's some examples of
essentially the same code and
how it gets compiled.
So here we're going to have
a fou1, fou2, fou3.
And in this case we declare
x, y, and z
to be unsigned integers.
We set them to some values.
And we just simply say
return x plus y or z,
bitwise OR with z.
If you look at what the code is
that's generated, it says
move the constant 45 into EAX.
Why does it do that?
Well, let's just see.
Well, the compiler figures out
that it knows what 35, seven,
and 45 are.
It computes x plus y.
That's 41.
If you take 41 bitwise OR with
45, it turns out it's masking
the same bits, that's 45.
So the compiler actually can
figure this out that all it
has to do is return 45
in a 64-bit register.
Ah, but here it's returning
it in a 32-bit register.
What happened?
It's not obeying the type.
The type is supposed
to be 64-bits, but
that's a 32-bit register.
Oh, yeah, that's this thing
where it automatically zeroes
out the high order bits.
And it uses this instruction,
because this is a shorter
instruction than if
it did the RAX.
It could do the same thing with
RAX, but it would be more
bytes of instruction.
So they saved a couple bytes of
instruction by doing that.
So people follow what
happened there?
Let's take a look
at the next one.
Here it's the same code
just let's pass
those things as arguments.
Well, if you remember the
calling convention, parameter
one is in RDI, parameter
two is in RSI, and
parameter three is in RDX.
So I don't expect you
to remember that off
the top your head.
But we have the cheat sheet, and
you can figure that out.
So here's what it does is, oh
my goodness, what is that
instruction?
This is actually a computation
of effective address.
So the effective address is
basically saying, and it's
using one of these funny
indexing modes.
So what this is actually doing
is it's actually adding these
two numbers together, the
values stored in those
locations together, and
storing it into RAX.
And then it's then OR-ing RDX,
what's in RDX, with RAX and
then returning.
Remember that RAX is where the
result is always going to be.
So the result is always
returned in RAX.
So you can see you have to do a
little bit more complicated
addressing in order to pull them
out as parameters than if
it could actually figure out
what the numbers are.
Last example here is I declared
these things before I
ever got their globals.
And so I declared them
before I ever got in.
So that means since they're
globals, they have a fixed
place in memory.
And so the code that's generated
is moving, it turns
out it allocates them right
nearby the instructions here.
And so what it does is it has
actually a relative offset for
x, relativity instruction
pointer, put that in RAX, add
the offset of x into it, and
then OR it with the offset of
z, and then return.
And so there the constants are
actually stored right nearby
in the code so that they can
use this relative offset.
And the compiler figures out, or
the assembler figures out,
exactly what the offset is
that it actually needs to
substitute for y so that it can
be a relative offset from
the current instruction
pointer.
Notice that, for example,
that's going to change
depending upon the
value of y here.
It's going to change compared to
if I accessed y down here.
It would be a different
instruction
pointer at this point.
So it actually just goes but
it computes what the
difference is so it knows
what the distance is.
It can compute that at compile
time, and then at execution
time it just uses whatever
constant goes in there.
So the important thing here is
just to notice that the code
depends upon where x, y,
and z are allocated.
So the first thing to actually
look at good code is to
understand the calling
convention
that's used by the compiler.
And here are the basics of it.
So the register RSP points
to the function
call stack in memory.
And the call stack grows
downward in memory, like in
that little map I showed you
before, so that as you push
things onto the stack they're
getting lower numbered not
higher numbered.
The call instruction pushes
the current instruction
pointer onto the stack, jumps
to the call target operand,
which is basically the address
of the thing you're calling.
So when you do a call,
it saves your return
address on the stack.
The return instruction pops
the return address off the
stack and returns
to the caller.
It basically says, oh, I know
where the return address is.
I slam that into the current
instruction pointer, and that
becomes the next instruction
that's executed.
Now, there are some software
conventions that are used
that's helpful to know.
Besides those instruction
registers, some of the
registers are expected to be
saved by the caller, some are
expected to be saved
by the callee.
You're free to violate this in
your own little piece of code
as long as if you're calling
something else,
you're obeying it.
So you don't have obey this
convention in the code you
write unless you want to
interoperate with other stuff.
So if you, for example, have a
leaf procedure, you can decide
for that leaf procedure, oh,
I'm going to make something
callee saved that was caller
saved or whatever as long as
by the time you return you've
cleaned everything up for the
rest of the world.
So these are conventions.
But for the most part, you're
not going to violate these,
and the code that the compiler
generates doesn't violate
these because it expects
everything to interoperate.
So here's how the subroutine
linkage works.
We're going to do an example
here where function A calls
function B which will call
function C. And right now,
we're at the point we're
executing B. And so on the
stack are the arguments that
were passed from A to B that
did not fit within
the registers.
So normally most of the
arguments are within registers.
But if you exceed the six
registers then, because you
have a long argument
list, then it gets
passed on the stack.
And here's where
it gets passed.
The next thing is B's
return address.
This is the thing that
got smashed in there
when you did the call.
It got pushed onto the stack.
And then there's what's called a
base pointer for A. And this
is the way that A ends up
accessing its local variables.
And then there's a separate
region here where it's going
to put arguments from B to B's
callees if they exceed the six
registers, if any of the things
that B is calling
require more than the
six registers.
So let's just take a look.
So function B can access its
nonregister values by indexing
off of RBP.
So these we say, these are
in a linkage block.
And the reason is because
it's actually part of
A's frame as well.
It's a shared part of the frame
where A stores it into
memory and then B's going to
fetch it out of memory.
And that's the linkage block.
So this is positive in memory.
So if I use a positive offset,
I then go up to getting the
arguments from A. Then it can
access its local variables
from the base point with a
negative offset because we're
growing down in memory.
Now, if it wants to call C, what
it does is it places the
nonregister arguments into the
reserved linkage block here,
which are arguments from
B to B's callees.
And that once again acts just as
if they're local variables.
It's positive index off of RBP,
sorry, negative offset
off of RBP.
So it pushes those things into
the argument, into that
region, if it needs to
use that region.
Then we actually, once it's done
that, we have the call.
So B calls C which saves the
return address for B on the
stack, so it saves it on the
stack, and then transfers
control to C. So now it starts
executing C's code.
And what does C do?
So C is going to have to advance
these pointers to
refer to its region
rather than B's.
It does it by saving B's base
pointer on the stack.
So it saves this pointer here so
that it can restore it when
it returns.
It advances, it sets its new
base pointer to be where the
stack pointer is now and then
advances the stack pointer to
allocate space for C's local
variables and linkage blocks.
Watch, here we go.
So that ends up being
C's frame.
So notice that B's frame and C's
frame are overlapping in
the linkage block
between them.
Now, if a function never
performs stack allocations
except during function calls,
there's a great compile time
optimization that the compiler
will often do.
And what it will do
is realize that
this distance is constant.
So, therefore, it doesn't
need RBP.
It can just do the math and
index everything off of RSP as
long as RSP is always the same,
for example for C, when
C is executing.
There's certain C commands
like [? alaka ?]
which changed the
stack pointer.
If you use those, the compiler
can't do that optimization.
But if the storage on the stack
never changes for a
given frame, then it's free
to make this optimization.
So you'll see code where RBP
has been optimized away.
How about some questions
before we go
on and do an example.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
should there be A's return
address, where you try to
[INAUDIBLE]?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Up?
Oh, this should be,
sorry, this should
be A's return address.
Yes, you're right.
OK, good, typo.
Is somebody catching
my typos to--
OK, yep, a good one, that should
be A's return address.
Sorry about that.
This is B's return address.
Any other questions?
That's good.
That means you understand
something.
Hooray.
So let's do an example.
So here's my fib example.
And I compiled this with
minus oh zero.
Because when I compiled it
with minus oh three, I
couldn't understand
what was going on.
So I compiled this with minus oh
zero, which gives me really
unoptimized code.
And that lets me be the
compiler optimizer.
So here's the code that
it generates.
So we can take a look at
a few things here.
First of all is declaring
fib to be a global.
And it's got some other
things here.
I actually took out some of the
directives that were in
here that were irrelevant
for our purposes.
If you actually compile it,
there's a lot more directives
that are stuck in there and a
lot more labels and things
that you don't need
to understand it.
There are two labels here.
And so you can see here
basically what's going on is
we're first of all doing the
advancing of the base pointer
and advancing the stack
pointer here.
That's doing that operation that
I showed you, those of
moving the base and
stack pointer up.
And then at the end here this
is equivalent to doing, a
leave instruction is equivalent
to undoing that.
So Intel lets you do one leave
instruction rather than making
you put these instructions
in every time.
It's exactly the same thing.
But in any case, let's
just sort of see
what's going on here.
So we're pushing some storage.
This is saving a
register here.
We're then advancing the stack
pointer to store 24 bytes of
temporary storage.
And then we're start to do
some computations here.
This looks like we're comparing
one with something
and then doing a ja.
So this is a jump above.
This is the unsigned version.
What you're looking is to see,
here we say if n is less than
two, in fact, what it's doing is
saying if n is greater than
one go to L4.
So it's actually doing
the other one.
So you can see then L4 is, what
happens is the one that
has the two calls to fib,
recursive calls, so that's
this part of the code, and
it's doing that if it's
greater than one.
And otherwise it's going to
execute these instructions,
which are basically
returning n.
And so it basically does
some computations.
And then both of them converge
here where it moves the
results and then pops
it off and so forth.
So that's sort of the outline
of what's going on there.
So let's dive in here a little
bit and sort of see what's
going on, see if we can read
this a little bit more closely
and whether we can
optimize it.
So the first thing that I
noticed in looking at this is
look at all this memory
addressing that we're doing.
What do you suppose this thing
is, minus 16% RBP?
So this is the base pointer.
So this is a local variable
because it's a negative offset
off of the base pointer.
What do you think it's
doing there?
What's stored in here?
Yeah, this is where
n is being stored.
Because what are we doing?
We're trying to compare n with
one here even though it says
two up there.
We're comparing it
with one here.
And so I look at that, and I
say, look, I'm comparing it
with one, then I'm jumping to
L4, then I jump to L4 or not.
And then let's say I don't.
Well, then the first thing I
do is I move n into RAX.
But wait a minute, I just
compared it with that.
So I'm accessing n again.
I'm accessing it a third time.
How about if I try to
store that stuff
in a register instead?
So what I did is I picked the
RDI register, because that one
happens to be available, and
I said do they, if you look
here, what did we do?
We stored RDI, which is the
first argument, into memory.
And then we compared
with it in memory.
Why don't we compare
with it in RDI?
Right?
Duh, stupid compiler, well,
because I had minus oh zero.
OK, so I can do that
improvement.
So what I did was I edited it to
put RDI there and RDI here
and RDI here.
And I went up and I said,
what about RDI here?
Why didn't I replace that one?
No, there's no loop
going on here.
It's recursion.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, the
problem is that when I call
fib, RDI gets garbaged on me.
Because RDI is going to be
the first argument to--
See it's being garbaged here?
It's garbage as far as
my use of it for n.
It's being used to pass n minus
1 as the argument to the
recursive call.
So I can't replace this one
after fib because RDI no
longer has it.
Because I had to leave it.
But even so I went from 5.45
seconds for the original code
to 4.09 seconds when
I compile that just
with that little change.
I felt pretty good.
So then I wanted more.
That was fun.
I wanted more.
So what was the next
thing I noticed?
I noticed that--
And by the way almost
all the things, that
stuff I did last night.
This is what I did an hour
before class so we'll see
whether it--
So then I noticed that, look,
we're moving this stuff here.
We keep using minus 24.
And once again, memory
operations are expensive
compared to register
operations.
Let me try to get rid them.
What do you suppose
is in here?
So look, we move RAX into the
local variable minus 24.
And then we jump to L5.
And we move minus 24 into RAX.
That seems kind of
unnecessary.
Here we move RBX
into minus 24.
Then we move minus
24 into RAX.
What is this value first of all
that I'm storing there?
What's going to be in
RAX at the very end?
RAX is the return value.
So I'm trying to save, here in
this case, this is the branch
where I just want to return n.
I just want to put RAX
to have it return, be
in RAX when I return.
So I've got the value here.
It's just n.
It was in RDI.
It's now in RAX.
But that's clearly
unnecessary.
Why go put it into memory and
then take it back out again?
And here just put it
in RAX directly.
So that's what I did.
I basically, instead of moving
it here, I changed this
instruction that said add it
and put in RBX, I said, no,
don't put it in RBX.
Let's just add RBX into RAX,
and then it's right there.
And this one, get rid of those
so that it's now moved into
RAX and it's in RAX.
So I did that.
I dropped to 3.9 seconds.
That felt pretty good, too.
In addition, I got rid of
this extra variable.
So now I could actually reduce
my storage requirements.
However, when I measured it
with this being 24 and not
being 24, it was
the same speed.
So it's like, eh, but
I didn't want to
waste the storage anyway.
So then I looked a little
bit further.
And I noticed that I
want to get rid of
this access to n here.
So basically I'm subtracting
it, and I'm storing n.
How can I get rid of it?
And this took me a little
while to figure out.
What I realized is, look,
we're storing
stuff away in RBX.
We have RBX as an available
register because I saved the
value of RBX with this push
instruction there.
So RBX is an available
register.
We're using it to keep the
return value of the
first call to fib.
So I'm going to use it for their
first call to fib so
that when I make the second call
to fib I can then add the
two things together.
Well, how about if before the
first call the fib, why don't
I use it to store the value of n
and then use it to store the
value of the return value
of fib of n minus 1?
So I did that.
And that took a little
bit of moving things
around a little bit.
But I managed to get rid of it
by using RBX for two different
purposes, one to store the
temporary, the value of n, and
the other to store the return
value when I need it.
And when I did that, I
got it all the way
down to 3.61 seconds.
I actually ran it with
minus oh three,
took about two seconds.
So I think I can keep
my day job.
But kind of fun to go in and
sort of see what are the
things that can be done.
And you can get a very good
sense of what's going on.
The more important thing is
when you look at compilers
generating your code, as we
saw on the last lecture on
profiling, you can see, oh, it
did something silly here.
So you can actually go
and say, oh, it's
doing something silly.
We can do a better
job than that.
Or, oh, I didn't realize I'd
declared this an int when in
fact, if I declared it a
unsigned int 64, it actually
would produce faster,
better code.
Yeah?
Question?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
So when you said that when you
run it with minus oh three,
what you're just saying is even
though you optimized the
[INAUDIBLE]?
CHARLES LEISERSON: As the
compiler, that's why I said I
can keep my day job.
So simple optimization
strategies, if you're playing
with things, is you try to keep
values and registers to
eliminate excess
memory traffic.
You can optimize naive function
call linkage.
And the most important thing
probably is constant fold.
Look to see where you've
got constants that
can be combined together.
There are other optimizations
that compilers do like common
subexpression elimination
and so forth.
But these are sort of the ones,
if you're doing it by
hand, these are sort of things
to focus on, particularly
number one, just get rid of
excess memory traffic.
Let me say, by the way, in doing
this I also went down a
bunch of dead ends, things that
I said, oh, this should
definitely save, and
then it was slower.
And then we look at it, and it
turns out, oh, my branch
misprediction rate is going
way up and so forth.
That's why you have
a profiler.
Because you don't want
to do this blind.
Now, how does the compiler
compile some common high level
structures?
So if you have a conditional,
for example, if p, do the
ctrue clause, else do the cfalse
clause, what it does
basically is it generates
instructions to evaluate p.
And then it does a jump with the
condition to see if p is
false to the else clause and
executes those instruction.
And then otherwise it passes
through, does the true clause,
and then jumps to the end.
And you'll see that pattern in
the code when you look at it.
So that's a very common
pattern for doing
conditionals.
Compiling while loops is kind
of interesting because most
while loops start
out with a jump.
So here are the instructions
for the body
of the while loop.
And here's the test.
And what they usually do is they
jump to the test, they
evaluate the condition,
and if it's true,
they jump to the loop.
Otherwise, they fall through.
And then they go back, do the
loop sometimes for the first
time, et cetera.
So that's kind of the pattern
for a while loop.
For a for loop, they basically
just convert it
into a while loop.
You basically take the
initialization code.
You execute that.
Then while the condition is
true, you do the code followed
by whatever the next code is.
And so it ends up converting
for loops into while loops.
Now, arrays are, how do we go
about implementing data types?
Arrays are just blocks
of memory.
So you can have basically three
different types of array
depending upon where it gets
allocated, either allocated in
the data segment, allocate
on the heap, or
allocated on the stack.
Sometimes even the static
arrays these days can be
allocated in the code segment,
if you're not
going to change them.
So one thing is to understand
that arrays and pointers are
almost the same thing.
If you have an array, that's a
pointer to a place in memory
where the array begins.
And a zero is the same as the
value you get when you
dereference the pointer to a.
A pointer, if you think about
it, is actually just an index
into the array of all memory.
And the hardware allows
you to index into the
array of all memory.
Well, it can also allow you to
index into any subregion of
that memory.
And that's why arrays and
pointers are basically the
same thing.
Here's a little quiz.
What is eight of a?
AUDIENCE: The a elements?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, it's
basically a of eight.
It's basically a of eight
because the addressing that's
going on is essentially
the same.
Even though we prefer
to write it--
If you start writing code like
this, I guarantee that at some
companies they'll get very angry
at you even though you
say, it's the same thing.
But what's going on is you're
actually taking the base, the
address of a, you're adding
eight to it, and then
dereferencing that value.
And indeed, even in C, they
actually do all the coercions,
even if eight is a different
type, it actually does the
coercions properly
so that they are
actually the same thing.
Because it does them after
it's converted it into a
dereference of a plus 8.
So it's kind of interesting
that it works right even
though when I looked at that I
say, well, what if it's bytes
verses words and so forth?
Yeah?
Question?
AUDIENCE: Will there be a
performance difference between
putting data on those three
different arrays?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes,
there can be.
In particular, static array,
it knows exactly where the
base pointer is as a constant.
Whereas the others it has to
actually figure out where it
is in the heap you need
a pointer to it
to dereference it.
It can't put it right into the
instruction stream itself.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
those would be just constant
[INAUDIBLE], right?
So I can either put that in
the static array or--
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes,
generally it's faster to have
it in a static array
if you can.
I want to finish up
here so that--
We have structs.
Structs are just blocks
of memory also.
So you can have a bunch
of things here.
This is a bad way to declare a
struct because the fields are
stored next to each other
generally in the
order you give them.
So here it says it's x and
then i and double.
What happens here is you
have to be careful
about alignment issues.
So if you do [? char, ?]
it's then got to pad it
out to get to the next
alignment for an int.
And it's got to pad that
out to get the next
alignment for a double.
Whereas if you do it in the
opposite order, it starts
packing them.
So generally it's best to
declare longer fields before
shorter fields because then you
know when you're finished
with the longer fields,
you're already
aligned for shorter fields.
Like arrays, there are static,
dynamic, and local structs.
So that's all they are.
And so you'll see in
the indexing--
There's also stuff that--
and actually this is important
for one of the binary puzzles
we gave to figure out
what it does--
there are what are called
SIMD instruction.
This is single instruction
multiple data instructions
where a single instruction
operates on
multiple pieces of data.
They operate on smaller
vectors.
And there are 16 128-bit XMM
registers, which you can view
as two 64-bit values or
four 32-bit values.
And you can do an
operation on it.
So this is used for multimedia,
for streaming
applications, and so forth where
you're trying to shove a
lot of data through and you're
doing the same repeated stuff
on the things at time.
So there are instructions that
operate on multiple values.
For example, here we're moving
four 32-bit ints into this
particular XMM register.
And similarly here's another
one, we're adding it.
And you can look at the
manual for these.
So you may come across these
because they're using up parts
of the machine.
Mostly those are the kinds of
things we can say look it up
in the manual, because nobody's
going to remember all
those instructions.
Of course, if you get a job
with one of the graphics
companies, then you may become
very familiar with these kinds
of instructions.
There's a lot more C and C++
constructs that we don't have
to go into.
You can have arrays of structs
versus structs of arrays.
And there can be a difference
in performance.
If you have an array of structs,
then it makes it, if
you're accessing one struct,
you can access the other
structs very easily.
But if you're using things like
the SSC instructions,
then it may be better to
have structs of arrays.
Because then when you're access
an array, you can
stream what's called a stride
of one, a regular stride of
just one memory location after
the next, to do the
processing.
So the hardware doesn't work
as well if you skip by
seventeens to gather things
compared if you just get one
thing after the next.
Because there's prefetching
logic that tries to fetch
things from memory faster.
There are things like
function pointers.
So you can have store function
pointer into something and
then call that function
indirectly.
There's things like bit
fields in arrays.
There are objects, virtual
function tables.
We'll get into some of
these when we do C++.
And there's a variety of stuff
having to do with memory
management that we'll
talk about.
But this is mainly to get you
folks sort of at the level
where you can sort of
understand and feel
comfortable with dealing
with the assembler.
And you'll see that
those resources
are pretty good resources.
But the basics are relatively
simple, but it's hard to do it
without a manual or some online
reference material.
Any questions?
What are the first two lessons
I taught you today?
Number one is--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: --write tests
before you write code.
And what's the second lesson?
AUDIENCE: Pair programming.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Pair
programming, not divide and
conquer, I teach algorithms
where divide and conquer is a
fabulous technique.
With programming, pair
programming is going to have
you generally get where you
want to get faster than if
you're programming alone.
OK, thank you.